we're exploring the physics of
basketball featuring my interview with
NBA all-star Kareem abdul-jabbar check
it out
a rebound in basketball you have to get
a sense of how the thing is going to
bounce before the thing makes that
bounce so that you can be in the right
place at the right time what's going
through your head when you how many how
many rebounds
was it aphelion 17 17,000 rebounds the
angle in equals the angle out so if our
shot comes from this angle at the basket
the probability is it's going to take
the same angle coming off the other side
by the way that's a law it's a law of
optics the angle of incidence equals the
angle of reflection it's like a mirror
so you have to understand the angle
that's going to come off and then the
distance from the from the rim and
backboard that you need to be at to have
the optimum opportunity to collect the
Reno plus 101 inch wingspan the ability
to anticipate is so we can spend 10
minutes you telling me I calculate the
angular but then really I just reach out
and grab the ball no some people just
stand there you got to move but so you
were particularly potent because you
basically combined your 100 100 inch
wingspan with the knowledge of angle of
incidence and angle of reflection right
and what we call hops
[Applause]
my dad I don't know that I use that word
hops cops is that's your vertical
vertical yeah basically that time vert
vertical yeah yo bro got hops like yeah
you can get up that's when you play
above the rim
you got hops you know he just told me a
little bit about his game oh we were in
a leaper oh no no I just did where I
grew up we didn't have that word we
didn't use that word yeah s o'clock yes
but I but I could jump all right
I could I could I couldn't UNK the ball
in ninth grade see you head hops that's
all there is to it yeah so you know yeah
I did not have hot
[Music]
you